all right friends and enemies and
detractors we've got to have a
conversation about libertarian
presidential candidate Gary Johnson Gary
Johnson is polling really really well
among Millennials he's he's kind of
doing pretty well
among Bernie Sanders supporters as well
and Gary Johnson is nearly tied with
Hillary Clinton among young voters among
voters 18 to 34 years old Hillary
Clinton's polling 31 Johnson 29 and
Trump 26
according to a recent a Quinnipiac poll
some of gary johnson's ideas at face
value seem somewhat progressive or maybe
at least appealing to progressives he's
mostly in favor of abortion rights he's
mostly in favor of LGBT rights he wants
to reduce the US military footprint
around the world he's Pro marijuana he
wants to scale back the war on drugs he
doesn't have a clearly clinically insane
running mate which is a really nice
thing I get it right I mean libertarians
have overlap with progressives even if
for different ideological reasons
sometimes the issues on which I agree
with libertarians I agree with them
really really strongly right a hundred
percent in many ways but aside from
these issues number one Gary Johnson
really lacks knowledge on many issues
but also his views on important issues
are completely opposed to the positions
of actual progressives not a single
progressive should be voting for Gary
Johnson I'll just tell you some of these
issues Gary Johnson's tax reform plan
would replace the income tax and the
payroll tax with a consumption tax a lot
of times right-wingers will call this
simplifying the tax code what it means
is making it better for rich people and
worse for poor and middle-income people
back in 2012 when he ran for president
he proposed a 43% across-the-board
single year federal spending cut
progressives are against haphazard
cutting of federal spending when you're
talking about 43% I know all about
government
I know all about reducing defense
spending and so many other areas of
spending that we need to look at but one
year cutting 43 percent to federal
spending any reasonable person knows
that you are going to be doing some
damage when you do that Gary Johnson
says he would bring the budget into
balance completely through spending cuts
because he has barred any tax increases
any thinking progressive knows that that
is a recipe for disaster and an
impractical recipe nonetheless on the
subject of student loans Gary Johnson is
totally confused he believes the reason
that college costs are so high is
because of quote guaranteed government
student loans misusing the term
guaranteed seems not to even know what
that means in the context of lending
there's some evidence that federal
student lending might have slightly
increased tuition but it is very low on
the list for the increases that we've
seen in the in the cost of college
tuition he's publicly stated that he
doesn't think the government should get
involved in climate change what
progressive could possibly vote for
someone who believes that Gary Johnson
supports the trans-pacific partnership
he supports citizens united because you
know it's freedom to donate to
politicians gary johnson is against all
forms of gun control what progressive is
against all forms of gun safety
regulations it makes no sense Obama care
and health care gary johnson believes
and this is this is just disturbing
gary johnson believes that the free
market should be involved in health
insurance period that is maybe the most
depraved possible position on the issue
of health care this is a disaster
protest vote ideological vote for gary
johnson forget about it now what's
happening why is he doing well with
progressives number one there are some
millennial progressives that are focused
on only the issues on which
libertarianism is appealing right the
issues i mentioned earlier abortion LGBT
rights etc number two you could you
could argue maybe it's possible that
millennials don't care
about the disagreements between
progressive ideas and Gary Johnson's
ideas because they want to sort of send
the middle finger fu to the major
political parties and number three
there's also the possibility that
because Millennials are increasingly
registered as independence they may be
sort of falling prey to this idea that
oh I'm an independent so therefore I
shouldn't vote for a Democrat or a
Republican I'll just pick one of these
third party candidates to vote for no
matter what the reasons are it is
ridiculous for progressives to vote for
Gary Johnson and I've met a couple of
them personally and I've had a pretty
good success rate and talking sense into
them most of them had no idea about Gary
Johnson's positions on TPP student
lending health care etc but I can't talk
to everybody so hopefully progressives
that are listening can take action on
this and help out